[Música]
les doy la bienvenida a un nuevo
episodio de boleto de vuelta que en esta
ocasión nos lleva a la unión soviética
en 1991 mijail gorbachov era su líder
fue bien visto por occidente porque
acabó con la guerra fría y la carrera
por las armas nucleares pero de manera
interna sus reformas económicas y
sociales eran cuestionadas la escasez se
multiplica la corrupción y el crimen
organizado van en aumento en agosto de
ese año ocurre el golpe de estado en
moscú mientras mijaíl gorbachov se
prepara para firmar un tratado para dar
más autonomía a las 15 repúblicas de la
unión soviética los partidarios de línea
dura del partido comunista se rebelan le
ponen al presidente soviético y los
tanques entran en moscú pero el golpeo
fracasó en gran parte gracias a un
hombre boris yeltsin entonces presidente
de la república de rusia y su discurso
contra la junta mientras está subido a
un vehículo pintado cambiará la historia
gorbachov está de vuelta en el cargo
pero ahora está debilitado por y chelsea
es el nuevo hombre fuerte prohíbe las
actividades del partido comunista en
suelo ruso y una por una la república
soviética recuperan su independencia el
25 de diciembre de 1991
mijail gorbachov anunció su renuncia y
la bandera soviética ya no ondea sobre
el kremlin 30 años después de su caída
nuestros reporteros volvieron a las
antiguas repúblicas soviéticas para ver
hasta dónde han llegado
mira a unos 350 kilómetros por encima de
la tierra en su interior sergei krikalev
observa cómo se desmorona la unión
soviética una rusia arruinada
hereda del programa espacial soviético y
pide al cosmonauta que se quede y salve
la estación espacial necesite azul
prusia tenía una necesidad absoluta por
economizar los lanzamientos de cohetes a
ellos y como debía ver a alguien dentro
de la estación para hacer el
mantenimiento se le pidió adquirir cal
efe que entendiera su estado
explícale para cuanto a 311 días antes
de que alemania decide a gastar 24
millones de dólares para enviar a uno de
sus ciudadanos a la estación permitiendo
que rusia lo devuelva el último
ciudadano soviético acaba de convertirse
en el primer héroe espacial ruso
inicial
cuando krikalev aterriza el imperio
comunista se ha dividido en 15 países
independientes
de hierro cae para revelar una recesión
económica la gente se enfrenta a la
escasez de alimentos y a la
hiperinflación los tres estados bálticos
deciden rápidamente liberarse de la
influencia de rusia se dirigen a la
unión europea estonia invierte
masivamente en nuevas tecnologías y abre
su mercado con tres objetivos erradicar
la corrupción la burocracia y la pobreza
esto ya lo entendió hace 30 años no era
posible seguir haciendo las cosas de la
misma manera
hoy en día el 99% de los trámites
administrativos se pueden hacer en línea
los impuestos son bajos y los negocios
prosperan
hoy en día estonia tiene el mayor número
de empresas emergentes por habitante
cuando el negocio es fácil se desarrolla
gracias a esta política de cero trámites
burocráticos las empresas emergentes
representan el 10 por ciento del pib
esta antigua fábrica aerospacial alberga
ahora pactó una empresa que ofrece un
software basado en la inteligencia
artificial que renegocia automáticamente
los contratos entre las empresas y sus
proveedores yo pretendo ser un proveedor
y la empresa me contacta para tratar de
mejorar el contrato para dar más partes
algunas empresas historias han tenido un
gran éxito como skype
la economía de estonia es la más
desarrollada entre las antiguas
repúblicas soviéticas
estonia es claramente el mejor lugar del
mundo para montar una empresa a marilyn
technical skills and diving global and
vision
estonia entró en la unión europea y en
la otan en 2004 el antiguo enemigo de la
unión soviética está ahora a las puertas
de rusia moscú no pudo detener el cambio
pero tomó represalias tres años después
con el primer ciber ataque a un estado
estos ataques han pasado a ser conocidos
en la historia como la primera vez que
se utilizan los ciberataques con un
objetivo político
estos ataques de 2007 demostraron tanto
a los responsables de la toma de
decisiones como a la gente ver que los
ciberataques pueden ser tan graves como
los ataques físicos y que la
ciberseguridad forma realmente parte de
una seguridad global
georg rusia nunca ha atacado
militarmente a un estado miembro de la
otan no sigue siendo un vecino
intimidante con una concentración de
tropas realizando constantemente grandes
ejercicios en la frontera tal como
sucede cada cuatro años
una amenaza respaldada por un historial
de invasiones militares en las antiguas
repúblicas soviéticas
en 2008 las tropas rusas entraron en
georgia para defender a una minoría
separatista prorrusa en osetia del sur
los combates duraron nueve días usaron
más de 1000 muertos y desplazaron a
150.000 personas a pesar de la presión
de la comunidad internacional el
ejército ruso nunca se retiró 13 años
después kilómetros de alambre de púas
marca lo que se ha convertido en una
frontera de hecho que ya no tenía un
terreno allí pero me encerraron con esta
cerca y lo perdí
los familiares no vienen aquí porque es
incluso en la línea serán arrestados
aquí
20 bases militares rusas están
repartidas a lo largo de la línea de
demarcación de 350 kilómetros de
longitud
diariamente nos enfrentamos al llamado
proceso de fronterización nos
enfrentamos a la detención ilegal de
personas también nos enfrentamos a los
ejercicios militares sobre el terreno
así que como rusia está desplegada en
nuestra tierra ilegalmente y están
ocupando nuestra región están tratando
de tener una política de adicción sobre
el terreno es una amenaza para la
seguridad europea en general
también se acusa a rusia de trabajar
para socavar la influencia occidental en
el país la oración dominical es popular
en esta sociedad profundamente religiosa
tras la independencia la iglesia
ortodoxa georgiana se convirtió en la
columna vertebral del estado georgiano
inventando la sociedad en torno a sus
valores tradicionales
la religión ocupa un lugar muy
importante en mi vida a esta iglesia en
particular le tengo un cariño especial
vengo aquí desde que tenía cuatro años
el país debería ser libre debería estar
libre de influencias y restricciones
negativas
especialmente libro de cualquier
influencia extranjera
hacia el 84 de los georgia nos definen
como cristianos ortodoxos muchos sienten
que sus tradiciones se ven amenazadas
por los valores liberales occidentales
ya que el país se prepara para solicitar
formalmente su adhesión a la unión
europea en 2024
por supuesto que la iglesia apoya la
idea de que georgia se convierta en una
democracia occidental
y somos parte de europa
no deberíamos perder nuestra cultura
nuestras tradiciones y sustituirlas por
otras
si la gran mayoría de los georgia nos
apoya la candidatura del país a la unión
europea la mayoría también rechaza las
políticas del bloque en materia de
derechos lgtb de julio de 2021 se
canceló una marcha del orgullo en medio
de protestas y violencia alrededor de
4000 personas fueron movilizadas por la
iglesia y estaban allí para rezar frente
al parlamento era como una protesta
pacífica anti él gmt pero alrededor de
mil personas representaban esta fuerza
física activa que ejecutó la operación y
estaban dispersos por toda la ciudad ese
día también la bandera de la unión
europea fue quemada dos veces
para giorgi las protestas no se limitan
a la homofobia
no se trata de los derechos el g-20 se
utiliza se llama para socavar el camino
pro occidental pero la idea general es
que no se intenta desestabilizar el país
utilizando los derechos lg para crear
esta atención política en georgia con el
fin de atacar los valores occidentales
porque el derecho el gmt se considera
como algo que
por ahora el gobierno georgiano sigue
comprometido con sus planes de
integración en la unión europea
[Música]
en kiev ucrania miles de personas
salieron a la calle en 2013 para pedir
un camino hacia la integración en la
unión europea' la plaza maidán estuvo
ocupada constantemente durante más de
tres meses lo que provocó la dimisión
del presidente prorruso la respuesta del
kremlin fue rápida y brutal los
paramilitares entraron en ucrania para
apoyar a la población anti rusa desde
entonces rusia se anexó crimea y el
donbass está sumido en una guerra
latente
y
rusia ya está operando dentro de ucrania
que otra prueba necesitas
cuando capturamos prisioneros de guerra
tienen pasaporte ruso escrito
esta fábrica de ática está en primera
línea el enemigo está a sólo 100 metros
aquí la lucha nunca se detiene realmente
aún así no tienen ninguna estrategia
disparan a cualquier cosa en cualquier
momento puesto a finales de 2021 rusia
comenzó a concentrar tropas en la
frontera los observadores se preocupan
por una invasión pero estos soldados son
dudosos
ahora dicen que un ataque es inminente
que los rusos están concentrando sus
fuerzas no creo que ocurra él dirían
demasiados hombres
el gobierno ucraniano no tiene medios
para forzar la salida de los rusos así
que ha decidido contraatacar en el
frente ideológico
una ley votada en 2015 prohíbe todo
rastro de la era soviética hay que
cambiar el nombre de las calles y
ciudades con nombres de líderes
bolcheviques thor es una ciudad minera
en declive es un buen ejemplo de
conformidad con la ley ucraniana sobre
la condena de los regímenes totalitarios
comunistas y nacional socialistas o
nazis
[Música]
la prohibición de la propagación de sus
símbolos y se aprieta trabajando y
extender sings pasa a llamarse tres
doctores curado
[Música]
perkins llamado félix del ying fundador
de la infame checa la policía política
comunista responsable del asesinato de
cientos de miles de ciudadanos
soviéticos
con una persona nos llamaban iron félix
bueno imagino que era una de sus
características la dureza
pekín
en rusia sus estatuas fueron derribadas
hace tres décadas pero entonces se
mantuvieron con orgullo hasta 2015 en
ese momento andrew wood green un
activista se dio cuenta de lo poco que
la gente sabía realmente sobre de jeans
que
una chica dijo que era un general ruso
[Música]
una mujer dijo que era un hombre de
estado soviético que cuidaba de los
niños
eso demostró que la gente no conoce su
historia
para andrew la desmovilización es
necesaria
hay símbolos del totalitarismo estatuas
de personas que torturaron y mataron a
millones de sus propios ciudadanos
provocaron hambrunas
enviaron a la gente a pudrirse en los
campos deberíamos haber esperado unos
años más o debatir si eran realmente
buenos y dejarlos en su sitio claro que
no creo que todo se hizo de forma
absolutamente correcta
[Música]
mientras se retiran estatuas en ucrania
los rusos ponen otras nuevas
este es un monumento josef stalin se
inició por el 75 aniversario de la
victoria del pueblo soviético sobre la
alemania nazi es un tributo al
generalísimo al comandante en jefe que
salvó el mundo del fascismo
el siguiente paso de alexei shírov
construir un museo dedicado al dictador
aquí habrá un edificio de 20 metros por
40 será un edificio grande con unos 1000
metros cuadrados
es nuestra historia es la historia de la
unión soviética de rusia
es la historia de cada persona que vive
en rusia
stalin es mi héroe estaba esperando que
hubiese un monumento así desde hace
mucho tiempo es un reconocimiento por
sus cualidades
si realizamos
para pelé
no lo podemos creer estábamos pasando
por aquí y vimos un monumento a stalin y
para que mi abuelo murió en los campos
lo vigilaron en 1938 tirano sanguinario
para algunos héroe de guerra que derrotó
a los nazis para otros stalin es una
figura que divide a rusia alexei sabe a
qué atenerse a pesar de que su propio
abuelo fue asesinado en las purgas
estalinistas
stalin no lo hará esto fueron los
oficiales locales porque esta línea es
el responsable debería putin ser
responsable por lo que yo hago por
ejemplo porque es el jefe del estado la
ideología comunista está muy pasada de
moda pero la mayoría de los rusos les
encantan los hombres fuertes algo que
vladimir putin que gobierna rusia desde
hace más de 20 años comprendió muy
pronto quién es realmente no queremos
quemar puentes no pero si alguien
percibe nuestras buenas intenciones como
indiferencia o debilidad y pretende
finalmente quemar o incluso volar esos
puentes
entonces debes saber que la respuesta de
rusia será esto
cinética rápida
winston y los llamo del kremlin está
empeñado en llenar el vacío que dejó
hace 30 años el colapso de la unión
soviética
[Música]
con sus tácticas agresivas ha conseguido
volver a situar a rusia en el centro de
la escena diplomática y preparar el
terreno para una nueva guerra fría
[Música]
llegamos al final de este episodio de
boleto de vuelta a la unión soviética
recuerde que si quiere ver este y otros
contenidos en español puede visitar
nuestra página web france24 puntocom